>> NEW POLLING FROM PENNSYLVANIA
SHOWS DEMOCRAT SENATE CANDIDATE
JOHN FETTERMAN WITH A WHOOPING
13 POINT LEAD OVER HIS OPPONENT
TV DR. AND CREW TA ENTHUSE I
CAN'TS MEHMET OZ.
>> JOHN FETTERMAN POLLING OVER
MEHMET OZ.
>> CAN MEHMET OZ BEATS JOHN
FETTERMAN IN PENNSYLVANIA?
SGLOONGS ABOUT YOU NOW ONCE
TRAILING SUPPOSEDLY BY 13 DR.
MEHMET OZ HAS CUT HIS OPPONENT'S
JOHN FETTERMAN'S LEAD TO TWO
POINTS.
IT ISN'T JUST JOHN FETTERMAN'S
HEALTH DRIVING THIS SURGE, HIS
CAMPAIGN IS PRETTY MUCH ABOUT
NOTHING.
HERE'S A DISPATCH FROM HIS
LATEST RALLY.
HE TALKED ABOUT SANDWICHES,
SALADS, FRESH FRIES ON SALADS,
MORE SALADS.
HE SAID OZ WANTED TO BAN
ABORTION WITHOUT EXCEPTION AND
REDUCE CRIME WHILE MAYOR OF THE
BOROUGH OF BRADDOCK AND LEFT THE
STAGE.
ONE ALLEGHANY DEMOCRAT
FRUSTRATED WITH THE LACK OF MY
MEAT ON THE BONES OF THAT
CAMPAIGN SAID HE WOULDN'T VOTE
FOR OZ BUT I ALSO WON'T VOTE FOR
FETTERMAN.
I'LL JUST LEAVE THAT BLANK.
THERE'S NO THERE THERE.
OKAY, THOSE ARE FETTERMAN'S
SUPPORTERS SAYING THAT.
JOINING US NOW IS DR. MEHMET OZ.
DR. OZ, GOOD TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
IN YOUR MIND AND OBVIOUSLY
YOU'RE OUT THERE EVERY DAY
CAMPAIGNING ALL OVER THE STATE.
WHAT IS MOST RESPONSIBLE FOR
THIS TURNAROUND IN THE SUPPORT
FOR YOU AND PEOPLE FLEEING HIS
CAMPAIGN?
>> I'M SHOWING UP.
VOTERS WANT TO KNOW THAT YOU
CARE, AND THE WAY YOU EXPRESS
THAT IS BY LISTENING TO WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING, WHICH IS WHAT
YOU DO AS A DOCTOR AS WELL, AND
THEN ADDRESSING THEIR KITCHEN
TABLE CONCERNS.
WHILE FETTERMAN'S TALKING ABOUT
THE TOPICS YOU JUST MENTIONED
AND LOTS OF OTHER ISSUES THAT
HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
CRISIS IN PENNSYLVANIA, I'M
TALKING ABOUT CRIME, THE HIGHEST
HOMICIDE RATE EVER IN THE CITY
OF PHILADELPHIA, I'M TALKING
ABOUT DRUGS FENTANYL IN
PARTICULAR AND THE OPEN BORDER
CAUSING IT TO KILL FOLKS IN
PENNSYLVANIA MORE THAN EVER
BEFORE, TOP FIVE IN THE COUNTRY
WITH FENTANYL DEATHS.
TALKING ABOUT THE 40 YEAR HIGH
OF INFLATION AND TAX RATES THAT
ARE THROUGH THE ROOF ADVOCATED
BY NOT JUST FETTERMAN AS A
CANDIDATE FOR THE SENATE BUT
ALSO AS LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR HE
WAS PUSHING FOR ALMOST A 50% TAX
INCREASE WHILE NOT PAYING HIS
OWN 67 TIMES.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT ELSE IS
HAPPENING, REPUBLICANS ARE
COMING HOME.
THEY'RE REALIZING THAT ALL THE
GARBAGE THEY WERE BEING FED BY
LEGACY MEDIA IS UNTRUE AND
VIEWERS OF YOUR SHOW ARE GOOD
EXAMPLES SUPPORTING ME AT
DR. OZ.COM MORE AGGRESSIVELY
THAN EVER BEFORE AND THAT'S
KEEPING UP WITH WHAT FETTERMAN
HAS BEEN GETTING ALL ALONG IN
CALIFORNIA AND NEW YORK
EVERYWHERE BUT PENNSYLVANIA AND
JUST WON A SENATE SEAT THEY
DON'T KNOW HOW DANGEROUS HE IS.
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE WHO
SUPPORTED ME AT DR. OZ.COM AND
ALLOWS ME TO TELL THE TRUTH
ABOUT FETTERMAN MORE THAN HE
LIES ABOUT YOU.
>> Laura: DR. OZ I KNOW YOU WERE
RECENTLY WITH BLACK PASTORS IN
PHILADELPHIA, I UNDERSTAND.
WHICH IS SO IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE REPUBLICANS, THEY'VE
BEEN INTIMIDATED FROM URBAN
AREAS.
THEY DON'T CAMPAIGN IN URBAN
AREAS, HUGE MISTAKE.
WHAT DID YOU DISCOVER WHEN YOU
CAMPAIGNED THERE?
>> FOLKS IN THE CITY OF
PHILADELPHIA ARE FURIOUS THAT,
AS THEY PUT IT, THEY'RE PART OF
A SOCIAL EXPERIMENT CONDUCTED BY
WHITE WOKE PEOPLE WHO DON'T
STICK AROUND FOR THE
CONSEQUENCES.
THESE PASTORS POINTED OUT A FEW
REALITIES THAT WERE SHOCKING TO
ME.
ONE, IF YOU LEGALIZE DRUGS WHICH
IS WHAT MY OPPONENT FETTERMAN IS
ADVOCATING FOR YOU WILL DRIVE UP
HOMICIDE RATES AND DRUG OVERDOSE
DEATH RATES.
IN FACT THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THE OREGON 2020 LAW.
THEY DECRIMINALIZED DRUGS AND
NOT ONLY OVERDOSE DEATHS BUS
WHOM SIZE WENT UP BECAUSE YOU
HAVE LAWLESSNESS.
THEY POINTED OUT SOMETHING THAT
STUNNED ME, THEY SAID YOU CAN GO
AROUND THE CORNER FROM MY CHURCH
AND BUY FENTANYL IT'S EASY AND
AFFORDABLE, WE CAN'T FIND BABY
FORMULA ANYWHERE.
WE HAVE ABANDONED OUR CITIES.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE REAL NEEDS, WE
CAN ADDRESS THEM, WE HAVE
SOLUTIONS, REPUBLICANS ARE THE
PARTY OF IDEAS, LET'S USE THESE
IDEAS TO ADDRESS THESE.
THESE FOLKS NOT JUST INNER CITY
BLACK POPULATION BUT MANY OTHER
ETHNIC GROUPS AND GROUPS
UNDERSERVED IN AMERICA WANT TO
BE REPUBLICANS.
THEY SHARE OUR FAMILY VALUES AND
WE SHOULD.
>> Laura: ENGAGE THEM.
>> REFLECT BACK, ENGAGE TH